two years ago Apple shocked the world
with the introduction of ask not to
track for the first time in forever a
big tech company was siding with the
people and preventing data collection
this update had real consequences as
well Facebook for example was losing as
much as 10 billion dollars per year in
Revenue just because of that little
pop-up this isn't too surprising though
as 96 of iOS users were disabling and
app tracking it despite Mark's pleas
that they opt in in the meantime Apple
was receiving a bunch of praise for
giving users the choice of course no one
was stupid enough to think that Apple
was actually doing this for the people
but it was concluded that this was
mainly just a marketing strategy Apple
has always advertised the iPhone with
the Allure of privacy so this move would
surely strengthen Apple's brand loyalty
and it might even convert some Android
users but what if I told you that all of
that was just stage one you see pushing
out Facebook and Google wasn't actually
a marketing move it it was an offensive
move now that Apple has effectively shut
off everyone from collecting deep data
on iOS users guess who advertisers have
to rely on to get access to iOS users
the answer is Apple this wasn't just
something that Apple stumbled into
either while they like to portray
themselves as the hardware giant that
just wants to create the best products
possible apple is actually becoming a
software company and the reasoning is
obvious and it's way more profitable you
know how Apple charges ludicrous amounts
for their products well even with that
pricing Apple's gross margin on their
products is only 37 percent their gross
margin under a seemingly cheap Services
however is a whopping 71 it looks like
offering services like apple music and
iCloud it not only Garners less
criticism but it's way more profitable
as well but by far the most profitable
service in the world is serving ads and
apple wants a piece of this pie so
here's Apple's master plan to take over
iOS advertising
this might seem like a recent
development but this story actually
dates back nearly 10 years to September
19 2014. this was the long anticipated
release date of the iPhone 6. rumors had
been Flying Wild for months people had
been camping outside of Apple Store for
days and the hype was Unreal Apple was
finally releasing larger format iPhones
at the same time the general public was
finally coming around to the idea of
spending several hundred dollars on a
smartphone and for many the iPhone 6 was
their first smartphone including myself
all of this culminated in apple selling
a ridiculous 220 million iPhone 6s and
the iPhone 6 pluses Apple had done
better than ever before but this was the
peak of iPhone sales every year after
that iPhone sales inch down step by step
this wasn't really Apple's fault the
reality was that smartphone progression
was rapidly slowing down phones lasted
for years and everyone who wanted an
iPhone already had one but while this
was a reasonable explanation Apple
couldn't just tell this to shareholders
if Tim Apple had done this well he
probably would have gotten the boot and
be replaced by someone who was quote
unquote more ambitious so Tim had to do
something his first instinct was to
raise prices I mean if you want to make
the same Revenue off of Lost units the
easiest way out is to just raise prices
with the iPhone 7 Apple increased the
price of the plus series by twenty
dollars and with the iPhone 8 Apple
increased the price of both series by a
total of fifty dollars but by far the
biggest jump in price came with the
iPhone x which came in at a thousand
dollars in the Western World this phone
was named as the thousand dollar Emoji
machine but this phone actually sold
extraordinarily well in China sending
Apple sales declined it seemed like the
increased pricing was working and apple
would double down on the strategy with
their next Generation the iPhone XR
would come in at an eye-watering 750 and
apple introduced a new Max version that
started at eleven hundred dollars we
have since gotten more used to these
prices but to this day when adjusting
for inflation these were the most
expensive iPhones that Apple has ever
released and this quickly became evident
in their performance sales were terrible
in fact they were so bad that Apple
didn't even want to tell us how bad they
were instead it they would just go ahead
and stop reporting unit sales numbers
altogether unsurprisingly Apple would go
ahead and reduce the starting price of
the iPhone for the first time ever with
the iPhone 11. this led to a much better
response with the public but this was by
no means an indie game for Apple they
were back to square one and they had to
not only address declining iPhone sales
but they also had to find new ways to
grow they were finding some success with
airpods and the newer Max but what they
really needed was a full-on new sector
as the they looked around them the
answer became obvious out of all the
tech Giants they were the only ones
focusing on Hardware everyone else was
focusing on software
foreign likes to Market themselves as
the premium company making premium
priced products and based on public
sentiment it seems like this messaging
has stuck really well everyone gives
Apple products as expensive luxurious
and exclusive but ever since the
disaster with the iPhone XR and the XS
Apple has actually been making their
products more accessible than ever back
in the day Apple would discontinue their
previous iPhones as soon as the new
version came out but nowadays they're
keeping around the older generations for
years and their models priced as low as
429 dollars in fact if you look at the
current pricing of the SE 12 and 13 it's
not much different from the pricing of
the pixel series which is known for
offering Great Value Apple will never
advertise this though as Google has
found out firsthand most people don't
actually want a value product what they
really want is a premium exclusive
product but for a value price and that
this is precisely what Apple has been
offering they have their fancy Pro
Series and their thousand dollar stand
and their 700 realist establish the
status of their brand but their real
Revenue drivers are their lower priced
products I mean if you're smart about
your trade-ins you can get an iPhone
that's one or two generations old from
your carrier for 100 200 Max you might
even be able to get it for free this
strategy doesn't just apply to iPhones
either Apple has made their lower tier
products value Centric across the board
I mean you can literally get the iPad
9th generation for 329 dollars even if
you spring for the iPad Pro it's
substantially cheaper than the flagship
iPhones the same thing can be said about
the Mac lineup as well Apple was already
offering great value with the M1 Mac
Mini that came in at 700 but they've
taken this to another level with the M2
despite all the inflation Apple didn't
just keep the price the same but they've
actually knocked it down to six hundred
dollars at that price the M2 Mac Mini is
arguably the best value desktop computer
on the market period you can see similar
Trends with the Apple watch and the
MacBook lineup as well but wait a minute
why in the world is Apple doing this
wouldn't these lower priced products
just exacerbate their revenue and the
profit margin problems well yes and no
obviously these lower priced products
will have much more modest Revenue per
unit and margins but they'll also sell
better this will keep the overall
revenue from each sector relatively
stable or even growing but net margin
will indeed go down and that's exactly
what Apple experienced for much of the
2010s between 2012 and 2020 Apple's
other net margin fall from 27 down to 20
this might not sound like a big deal but
when we're talking about hundreds of
billions of dollars worth of Revenue
this translates to tens of billions of
dollars worth of bus profit this is why
Apple's net income didn't increase all
that much during this time period
despite the revenue nearly doubling
Apple was okay with this though because
they had something much bigger in the
works and this was just stage one user
collection
as Apple offered more value-driven
products and unlocked more people into
the Apple ecosystem it was
simultaneously doubling down on their
services likely the most notable example
is Apple music fun fact Steve Jobs
actually needed the idea of Music
subscriptions he said that even Jesus
couldn't sell music subscriptions and
this was really the premise of iTunes as
a whole the idea of iTunes was that
people could buy virtually any track in
the world and to keep it forever for a
reasonable 99 Cents but apples craft
this idea altogether in mid-2015 when
they announced Apple music if you've
been living under a rock Apple music is
a music streaming subscription similar
to Spotify but unlike Apple's brand
damage Apple music was once again
reasonably priced in fact Apple music
was priced identically to Spotify pair
this with Apple's beautiful integration
with their devices and you end up with
88-9 users paying you 10 or more every
single month I'm that itself is nearly a
billion dollars per month but that's
nothing in comparison to their Cloud
business iCloud is once again priced
basically identically to Google Drive
but it comes along with the whole Apple
aesthetic and the convenience and Boom
by 2018 Apple had an estimated 815
million iCloud users out of which 170
million were paying Apple had found a
golden strategy they didn't have to
reinvent the Wheel by any means they
just had to take already popular
Services integrated into the Apple world
and offer it for the same price and boom
they suddenly had tens of millions if
not hundreds of millions of paying
subscribers they deployed this same
strategy with Apple TV Apple arcade
Apple news Apple Fitness AppleCare and
who knows what else this was working
relatively well by the end of the 2010s
but the real explosion didn't come till
the pandemic suddenly everyone was at
home and they needed even more virtual
entertainment than before they needed
more music or games or TV or media they
also had a bunch of money saved up from
not going on vacation and not going out
nearly as often so there was ordered to
spending much of their money on Tech and
guess who was in the perfect position to
take advantage of this well it was
actually all of the big tech companies
which of course included Apple within
the 12 months following the start of the
pandemic Apple's Revenue grew by over a
hundred billion dollars and their net
income at nearly doubled and today Apple
boasts an impressive event 935 million
paid subscribers worldwide in other
words 1 8 of the world has some sort of
paid apple-based subscription Apple had
done it they successfully transitioned
from being a hardware giant to being a
hardware slash software giant but after
wasn't satisfied they wanted to take it
one step further as they were still
missing out on the most lucrative
service of them all advertising
Apple wasn't just gonna start offering
ads like Google or Facebook though as we
all know Apple likes to do everything
the apple way with finesse and cover
positioning so they decided to leverage
public angst the Shady habits of Google
and Facebook were no longer a secret
their business practices were very much
public knowledge and people hated them
for it now of course people didn't hate
it enough to switch but they did hit it
enough to complain so what better way to
create an advertising Monopoly than
decide what the public and to block out
external data collection this was a
win-win-win-win scenario one apple was
hurting their brand image of their
competitors by basically suggesting that
what they were doing was wrong two they
were hurting the revenue and the bottom
line of their competitors big time 3.
they were both doing their own brand
image as the Privacy gang and four they
had ultimate controller over all
advertising within the Apple ecosystem
we should also note that Apple has been
experimenting with more team advertising
for several years now they've been
selling ad spots within the App Store
and app on you since 2016 actually so
they're by no means complete newbies to
the space but they're about to take this
to the next level since August Apple has
been hiring a substantial number of
Engineers to work on some sort of
large-scale AD platform it's expected
that this new platform will essentially
be Apple's version of Google or Facebook
ads but wait a minute Apple can't just
bash on Google and Facebook for years
and then turn around and do the exact
same thing right I mean Tim Cook himself
has argued that ad driven business
models are inherently invasive to
privacy so how could Apple make such a
pivot without destroying their branding
well the answer is likely by introducing
an aqua twist in other words they'll
throw in some encryption some
decentralization and some anonymity and
they'll frame it as something that
protects privacy we can all already see
something along these lines with their
hide my email feature if you're not
familiar with this feature it basically
allows you to generate a proxy email
address when signing up for websites or
emailing people Apple doesn't read or
process any of the emails that go
through this proxy address and I suspect
that they'll Implement something similar
when it comes to ads maybe all of the
data that they collect will be stored
locally on your device which will check
off the decentralization checkbox after
that maybe they'll use some sort of
anonymous proxy tunnel that's end-to-end
encrypted to connect advertisers to your
device this way they can claim that they
or the advertisers know your data
themselves they're simply a proxy that
connects advertisers and end consumers
while protecting your privacy or at
least that's what the pitch will
probably be
foreign
Apple was the only Mega tech company
that didn't drive most of their revenue
from software and services but over the
past several years this has been rapidly
changing the reality is that smartphones
have hit a plateau and apple can only
introduce the next iPhone that's better
than ever before and increase the price
so many times in fact I believe that
it's just a matter of time until Apple
drops the number naming scheme on the
iPhone before you know it the new iPhone
will be called the 2027 iPhone as
opposed to the iPhone 19. this will no
doubt reduce the hype surrounding iPhone
launches but that's okay by then Apple
will not only PS after a giant but it
will be a full-on software company their
iPhones Macs iPads and watches will
simply be a vehicle to sell their real
money producers subscriptions and
services it looks like the latest effort
in making this Vision a reality is
getting into ads and that's why Apple
really shut out external tracking what
do you think about Apple getting into
the ad business comment that down below
also drop a like if you respected the
business decision but hate the
implications and of course consider
checking out our Discord community so
just for the video ideas subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm already and I'll see
you guys on the next one
foreign